assume I lie it is humulin it's still
loominatee or real or is it fake
Illuminati which of course stands for I
love Louis uncle man um not a tit which
is a conspiracy theory that all artists
are part of the devil
I've found this secret device that will
help us determine if the artists and
celebrity is part of the Illuminati and
not yes
exhibit a Justin Biber Bieber now why
would a woman need to shave this is
already raising a few eyebrows let us
zoom in to find the answer we have to go
beyond the pixels in this one what is
this you go see it no what is this
creature and what does it want from us
let us reduce the pixels it looks like
some sort of demon I think we're on to
something
let's run it through the pixelating
program oh my god it turns out it was
just me cryin it was meg Ryan whatever
meg Ryan is doing in Justin Bieber's
mouth we're not gonna go into but it
looks like he's clear what disappointing
results but let's not give up except
it'd be a con super famous superstar
making great song sorry let me let me
redo that one making songs let's run it
through the Machine and see what we can
find
well since the program is detecting
multiple triangles there's more oh my
god they're appearing in multiple
locations what that doesn't even make
any sense where he's part of it - my god
I never seen anything like it
Aiken is Illuminati confirmed
let's not get ahead of ourselves here
let's keep it calm for the final test we
will compare a con with this reptile
let's see what the system says it
appears that's clearly not good enough
akin may or may not be eliminated but we
will never know until we have hard
evidence damn it we were so close now I
know what you're asking yourself has
science gone too far
Exhibit C Katy Perry you can clearly see
here in the Cleveland no I did not just
want to put a cleavage in the video damn
it shut up wait a minute
Makemake Ryan I could we have been so
blind bros how could we have been so
blind has anyone checked her mouth oh
god okay we're all jammed okay okay it
cleared
wait assuming then the reflection is
that gross do you see it what is that
there's something in the eye the answer
is in the eye just like in Illuminati
we'll have to run it through our scanner
this yeah no I don't believe it
No
no I I don't believe it it's Luis from
one direction
he's been hiding in the background of
the band we've all been so focused on
Harry's beautiful hair that we didn't
see what was right in front of us
you
share this video with everyone you know
we need to stop Lewis Thompson Thor
whirling soon I don't know what to
believe anymore